depuis les élections législatives
d'octobre 2010 9
la tunisie est toujours sans
gouvernement une vacance du pouvoir qui
risque de perdurer vendredi les députés
tunisiens ont rejeté le gouvernement
proposé par habib jamie premier ministre
désigné par le parti islamiste ennahda
seules 72 parlementaire sur 219 ont
approuvé ce nouveau gouvernement
bien loin des 109 voix nécessaires pour
son adoption c'est pas une déception
c'est une réussite que la démocratie
tunisienne qui se présentent à la paix
c'est normal vous ont payé un petit
train quand même nom n'y a pas de pré
savons rien de voir notre pays et notre
peuple notre nation donc c'est une
victoire pour la démocratie peut-être
mais un échec pour habib jamie et pour
le parti ennahdha qu'il avait choisi le
15 novembre dernier
de son côté le président du parti au
coeur de la tunisie nabil karoui déplore
une perte de temps pour la tunisie
elle est arrivée au parlement sans avoir
une majorité
donc quand on arrive sans avoir une
majorité va vous savez ce qui arrive on
a perdu 2 - c'est un monsieur canada a
pointé qu'elle a soutenu cependant il
n'est pas et n'a pas réussi à réunir une
majorité autour de sa personne son
gouvernement désormais et selon la
constitution tunisienne
c'est au président qu'il revient de
lancer des consultations pour trouver un
nouveau chef de gouvernement susceptible
de convaincre les députés et ce dans un
délai de dix jours
le nouveau premier ministre aura alors
un mois vous proposez un gouvernement et
le faire approuver dès le lendemain du
rejet par le parlement le chef de l'état
s'est emparé de cette mission samedi il
a débuté ses consultations en recevant
rached ghannouchi président de
l'assemblée est leader d'ennahda en cas
d'échec à l'issue de ces discussions car
ça y est tu pourra alors choisir de
dissoudre l'assemblée puis de convoquer
de nouvelles élections législatives
nadia chabane et ancien député à
l'assemblée constituante tunisienne elle
dénonce une ingérence donc haras à tunis
écoutez il ya une crise qui est en train
de s'installer au niveau de l'assemblée
puisque le président de l'assemblée
nationale au lendemain du vote est parti
en turquie pour une rencontre avec
cardinal est une espèce de de diplomatie
parallèle à l'oeuvre où il est parti au
nom de son parti paraît-il et non pas au
nom de l'assemblée
mais à la veille d'une rencontre avec sa
rage erdogan avec les enjeux de la
région
et là il ya un vrai vrai souci parce
qu'il ya quand même actuellement une je
crois une pétition qui circule au niveau
de l'assemblée pour une motion de
défiance donc il ya quand même une crise
aussi qu' une petite crise qui est en
train de s'installer autour de la
contestation au niveau de cette décision